I had so much I wanted to say
I had to prepare it on my phone so
forgive me
good morning
I'm honored to be here today to
recognize the man that we all knew and
love my dad Kobe Bryant
as his daughter I got to see firsthand
all the behind scenes he that he put
work in
watch him get up early in the morning
before anyone else is staying up late at
night past anyone else to continue
working
this is just a very small glimpse into
incomparable work ethic
when most people knew him as a
basketball player or storyteller
I got to know and love him as my dad
and let me tell you
he is the MVP of girl dads to say the
least
being the dad of four girls is
definitely not easy but despite the NBA
and Laker schedules
he always made sure to support me and my
sisters Gianna Bianca and Capri
at our recitals games
tournaments and any Monumental moment
you can think of
being his daughter is one of the
greatest joys of my life
and I hope to continue to embody and
cherish the many lessons he has taught
me
within our family
each of us have our unique ways of
expressing love
which can be referred to as our love
language
one may wonder why I've developed such a
fondness for movies like Star Wars Harry
Potter the complete Marvel Universe and
Goonies amongst many others
well the reason behind it is that I
watched all of these movies with my dad
and
each of those memories I will never
forget
he is the reason I'm pursuing film in
college and he is the reason film has
inspired me to create memories like ours
for other people to even bring more
fathers and daughters together like us
this all brings me to this moment
now which makes honoring my dad here 10
times more special and personal
to me in so many ways
it's truly astounding to be standing
here in front of the Chinese Theater in
Hollywood
forever displaying my dad's hands and
footprints
as you visit here for years to come
I encourage you to place your hands in
his and take a moment to stand in his
shoes
this will be a treasure for the city of
Los Angeles
and my dad's fans from all over the
world to hold and to cherish
he was the first ever NBA player to win
an Oscar for a short film and I am
extremely proud of him not only because
it's such an amazing achievement but
because I was able to witness all
the work leading up to that moment
I remember sitting beside him during
late nights whether I was working on a
school project getting a midnight snack
or unable to sleep
he would always be awake writing
storyboarding editing
and that story evolved into the story
that we all love and cherish dear
basketball
it is only fitting that my dad Kobe
Bryant
is the very first athlete to get their
hand and Footprints displayed here in
the city of Los Angeles
this day symbolizes the impact that he
has had on a city that he loved and
cared for so deeply
this also Embraces the Mamba mentality
and competitiveness
at being the first ever athlete
to ever accomplish this
now as I've gotten older
I continue to see the impact that he had
he had on those around him and the
inspiration he has brought to so many
from the professional athletes across
the world he's a moment mentality to
pursue their goals to fans from Laker
Nation and anyone who loved watching him
play
dad
you're an icon a legend a storyteller
and most importantly the best girl dad
any young woman could ever dream of
I'm honored to be here to represent you
and our family
and we are extremely proud of you
we will love you forever and always
love Natalya Gianna Bianca Capri and
Mommy
[Music]